is there a company that will run my
business for me I get it as an
entrepreneur you're not great at
everything okay you can't be great at
everything you need people to help you
build your business beyond where you
could take yourself okay that's part of
being an entrepreneur but don't let not
having people in your circle hold you
back from getting started I got a
question from one of my youtube viewers
love you guys Bernard Bernard rodin to
say I've had a website built for me but
i do not do or i do not know the
technology part is there a company that
will run my business for me and split
the profit and the short answer here is
yes okay you can find people you can
find companies who have not just
technology skills but any skills that
you need who can join you as a part in
your company but you gotta be careful
you got to watch out because this is
like getting married you're giving up a
piece of your company to somebody who
you need to trust will be with you for
the long term so you need someone who's
not just skilled in the areas that you
need you eat somebody's not just great a
technology but somebody who has the same
vision as you who has the same values as
you somebody you can stain being around
eight to ten hours a day every day it's
not important I don't want you to just
jump into a relationship because you're
desperate that's the worst way to do it
but I also don't want this to hold you
back from getting started because this
is where a lot of entrepreneurs fall
down they think I've got this great idea
but to do it I need to make you need to
have money I need to have fun than I
need to have a team or I need to have a
partner will help me with do with doing
the parts that i'm not good at I can't
do it all myself and as a result you
don't do anything and that's not the way
to get started don't use not having
money and not having a partner as a
reason to hold you back from getting
started there's no reason to hold you
back from getting started except you
this is on you to solve and if you're
not great at technology and don't make
technology a great part of your business
think about what you're really good at
and how you can apply that to your
company and make it successful here's an
example from Toronto okay I'm in
fester in Toronto dance all sides one of
the largest salsa dancing schools in
North America will teach five six
thousand people a year how to dance
salsa there's a new person who's coming
to the market kind of taking that the
high-end people who really want to train
to be professional dancers and she's an
artist and she's great at what she does
but she has no technology skills none so
what did she do very successfully she
launched on facebook she doesn't have a
website she teaches salsa dancing she
teaches people how to be great
performance level professional salsa
dancers that's what she does and
technology is not super important to her
company she focus on what she is really
good at and she's built her business up
all on facebook facebook is her website
and she got started now maybe as she
grows his sing up as she gets money
coming in maybe she realizes to expand
you know I want to invest in marketing I
want to invest more in technology and
she has money to do that but she didn't
let not having money and not having any
technology background stop her from
starting her business and she's had
success and you can too just focus on
what you're good at instead of letting
your weaknesses hold you back so the
answer the question yes you can find
somebody to be your business partner to
take on the things that you're not great
at but be very careful with it and if
you can't find that person that's not
life threatening find a way to make your
dream happen on your own and eventually
people will come if you have a strong
enough mission that people love what
you're doing people will rally around
you and want to support the cause and
you'll find potential partners and
you'll find potential employees to help
you grow but you gotta start okay you
got to start and do something every day
to move your business forward and don't
let any excuse any any person a lack of
skill hold you back from doing something
today believe
for those you watching like the video
give it a thumbs up below it always
makes me want to do more let me don't
you think leave a comment underneath you
have a question I make a video response
thank you so much and I'll see you soon